aujourd'hui sur vos meilleurs amis
pourquoi ce sont elles qui vont vous
aider à vous déplacer pour aller
chercher les ballons donc je voulais
travailler pas techniquement nous valent
au bout voudrais rien du tout se faire
un peu malmené par son entraîneur fait
partie des contraintes du pôle régional
de handball ces remontrances il alors
les années les aux vilains 17 ans les
acceptent d'autant plus facilement que
celui qui fait la leçon se nomme daouda
karaboue est là on attend le rebond tags
et on fonce sur la deuxième deux fois
champion du monde avec l'équipe de
france
cockpit a pu prouver la charge ce n'est
content d'être là parce que c'est des
gros séance de travail allait très bien
plus une voix ça nous permet de
progresser on a un échange avec daouda
qui est quand même un cas était un très
bon gardien avec un très bon entraîneur
mais que c'est bénéfique pour nous si on
veut pas être là et on pousse comme son
nom le dit tous les excédents sont six
doigts de leur exiger des valeurs d un
niveau d'exigence de
élevé puisque ceux qui sortiront d'ici
normalement seront appelés à continuer
dans la filière générale
donc c'est l'apprentissage dès le plus
jeune âge a lâché la bagarre n'est pas
là bas frédéric salma et le responsable
de ce pôle d'excellence masculin
chercher le décalage les arrières au
départ il mène un double projet avec un
groupe de 27 garçons âgés de 14 et 18
ans les garçons qui rentrent en
structures et les mêmes les parents
savent au départ que le scolaire était
mis en avant est le sportif est
aujourd'hui une passion et l'accès vers
le haut niveau mais l'un ne sera pas
sans l'autre
il y a une douzaine d'années c'est
valentin porte actuellement au mondial
avec la sélection française qui faisait
son apprentissage ici même et bien
entendu cela fait rêver les
pensionnaires de 2019
on est forcément motivé pour aller plus
loin possible et c'est ce que je veux
faire accéder aux centres de formation
et les équipes professionnelles derrière
ça demande beaucoup d'efforts beaucoup
de douceur représente aussi beaucoup de
fatigue
entre les entraînements où on souvent
très tard et comme là je suis en classe
de première s scène on aussi beaucoup de
travail en suisse à bâle froide
d'ailleurs en près de vingt ans
d'existence ce centre régional
d'information vingtaine de joueurs
professionnels et un seul membre de
l'équipe de france tous les autres en
sont sortis avec un diplôme est debout
souffrir